That was a good incremental step. Now, let's add back the parts
that make this into a real credit card verifying program. I'm going to
ask you to write one more Java program. And this time, I'd
like you to use this pseudocode. There's a tester program you can use
for guidance. And here's a hint. Credit card numbers are too big
for ints. This problem is tricky. There are a lot of ways
to write code that almost works, but not quite. It will be
very important to use the tester
program. You can also use System.out.println statements
to get an idea of what your program is doing. There will be more
hint videos. Try to use the ones that match the questions in your mind.